welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins sitting in for David
Pakman today you can follow me on
twitter at fair and balanced farr onbaa
la in ced it's the same on instagram and
on Facebook let's jump back into the
dues now let's get to the Democrats
right this past weekend Bernie Sanders
on Meet the Press said something that I
could not agree more with and I know
later in the weekend also Bernie Sanders
said some things that were really
insensitive but I got to talk about this
issue here because I think this really
hits the nail on the head with what the
20/20 campaign has to be about Bernie
Sanders during his Sunday appearance on
Meet the Press was asked about Joe
Biden's comment while campaigning a day
or two before where Joe Biden was asked
about his climate policy and he said
I'll tell you what my climate policy is
number one got to beat Donald Trump
everybody laughed everybody applauded
because that was Joe Biden's real answer
you want to make things better in this
country defeat Donald Trump so Bernie
Sanders comes along on Meet the Press on
Sunday it says listen Trump cannot be
the only goal of 2020 2020 cannot just
be about beating Donald Trump here's is
an exact quote here says beating Trump
is not good enough you have to beat the
fossil fuel industry you have to take on
all the forces of the status quo who do
not want to move this country to energy
efficiency and sustainable energy now
that's just on the issue of climate
change right but here we've seen it from
Bernie we have seen it from Kamala
Harris we have seen it from Elizabeth
Warren we have seen it from so many
other people Andrew yang Tulsi Gabbard
even Peapod edge edge people who
actually come out with policy nobody
more so by the way than Elizabeth Warren
but Biden's just out there saying we
want to do anything about these we got
to beat Trump because Biden is still
clinging on to to those polls or those
beliefs or whatever they are that he's
the only one who can beat Donald Trump
that's why we got to put all our faith
and
policy will come later don't worry about
that in fact about a week ago Biden also
told us he didn't have time to explain
his health care policy
I got a move on I got to worry about
beating Donald Trump you cannot and I
can't stress this enough you can't beat
Donald Trump if you're not out there
offering policies because I know it's
easy to get swept up in the big crowds
at these you know campaign events the
people cheering on these talking points
about beating Donald Trump you see it on
Twitter we've got to beat Trump that's
not the whole country though folks
that's not the average person going
about their lives in their homes because
believe it or not a lot of people in
this country have not been adversely
affected by Donald Trump's policies
they're not benefiting in any way from
them don't get me wrong but they haven't
exactly affected their day to day lives
you know their paychecks haven't
increased but they haven't decreased so
why would I jump ship things are okay
for me personally why would I want to
change this why would I want to risk it
and that's what Democrats have to do a
better job of explaining and and by
Democrats I mean all I don't know
eighty-five who are running for
president we've got plenty who are
explaining Sanders Warren Harris yang
these people are out there Tulsi Gabbard
again they're out there telling us like
this is what I want to do and this is
how it's going to affect you and again
nobody's doing that better than
Elizabeth Warren which is why her poll
numbers are finally starting to tick up
there a little bit but listen I'm not
advocating for one candidate or the
other at this point and I'm not trying
to discourage voting for anyone except
maybe Biden at this point because we're
still in the primaries and I can do that
without worrying if you like Biden fine
but why and be expected to answer that
question what is Biden offering that is
going to make your life better and don't
just say he's gonna beat Trump
that's a cop-out that is a very weak
answer with no substance behind it
because there's really not much evidence
to suggest that Biden will beat Trump oh
you want to look at the polling data the
same polling data that said that Hillary
Clinton was gonna run away with this
thing in 2016
be my guest but if you're putting all
your faith in that then be expected you
know you can go ahead and expect the
same kind of disappointment you had in
2016 what we need to be talking about
what every candidate needs to be talking
about is hard policy not just ideas
either you've got to have again I'm
going to use Elizabeth Warren as the
example because she has done it better
than anybody else you have to have the
roadmap you have to explain how we get
from A to B to C to D to the end goal
all the way every step of the process
you have to be prepared for the
Republican obstruction and you have to
understand and have a plan to counter
that because Republicans aren't going to
let these big ideas go through the green
New Deal the Medicare for all the $15
living wage ain't gonna happen
under the Republicans watch so you
better have a workaround unless of
course you are hundred percent certain
the Democrats are going to retain the
house and take back the Senate in 2020
it's all possible by the way there are
far more Republicans up for re-election
than there are Democrats in the Senate
we could do this we absolutely could do
this but not if you're just out there
saying vote for me because I'm not Trump
we tried that in 2016 and it failed what
did Trump do that was different
well we know who his base is and we know
why they supported him they they like
white people and nobody else we get that
part but there are plenty of Trump
voters who believe it or not not racist
average normal working-class folks and
he was talking policy he was talking
ideas bad ideas and bad policies that he
had no intention of following through on
but he talked about it folks and I think
people miss that in these conversations
and I think most of the Democrats who
are running for president understand
that they don't need this lecture they
don't need to hear me tell them to talk
about policy because they are you can go
to their websites and find every
possible issue under the Sun and find
out what they want to do and how they're
gonna do it but then there's Biden Biden
wants to come out be the happy feel-good
candidate be that maybe a little too
touchy-feely candidate but he wants you
to vote for him because he's not Donald
Trump and I'll be a hundred percent
right now I'm in Florida
a swing state I don't have the luxury of
a protest vote if Biden ends up securing
the Democratic nomination I'm a vote
from a / Biden I'm gonna I'm gonna hold
him accountable if he does something bad
I'm going to report on it but if that's
my only option I'll vote for Biden I'm
not gonna stay home I'm not gonna write
in somebody who doesn't have a chance
because again I'm in a swing state very
tough swing state - but until we get to
that point where a single person has
sealed the deal on who the Democratic
nominee is gonna be I'm gonna hold them
all accountable when Bernie sander
screws up I'm gonna call him out when
Elizabeth Warren does I'm gonna call her
same thing with Harrison Booker and boot
edge edge and I have and I do and I will
because that's our job it should not be
the job of any pundit YouTuber
progressive host it shouldn't be
anybody's job to just promote a single
candidate promote the issues and find
the candidate that fits those the best
yeah we've got some great people running
for president and I do have actually two
people in my head that right now I don't
know which one of them I'm gonna vote
for I love them both I think they're
both great and I think either one of
them would be a phenomenal
transformative figure in that White
House so I don't know yet but what I do
know is that I'm going to hold these
every one of these people accountable
and when they come off off message when
they start with the stupid talk of oh my
climate policy is to beat Donald Trump
ha ha ha that's not good enough
that's not gonna win my support in any
way shape or form climate policy is
climate policy beating Trump is just
part of that goal I want to know how
you're gonna fix the planet you know we
were told we had 12 years before we get
to the irreparable damage part of
climate change but keep in mind that was
over six months ago folks over six
months ago
so for Biden to go out there and even if
he was making a joke you can't joke
about things like this right now because
yeah it's pretty bad we can fix it we
100% could fix it and reverse it and
live long happy lives we talked about in
history books as the time when humanity
came together and fix the problem or we
could be known as the ones who continue
to let it get worse which is what's
happening now we no longer have 12 years
more like 11 and a half probably closer
to 11
considering that emissions have
increased and carbon in the atmosphere
has increased so that's kind of cutting
that clock down a little bit but don't
joke about the best way to solve the
climate crisis is to defeat Donald Trump
as Bernie Sanders said the best way to
defeat the climate crisis is to defeat
the fossil fuel interests to defeat the
big money fighting climate change policy
2020 is not just about Donald Trump and
any Democrat who tells you that is not
worthy of your primary vote